you're next hello Bill Murray how are
you I'm good how are you doing doing
fantastic especially here with you well
I'm going to be camping out again
tonight so you're welcome to sleep with
me outside whole age how many how many
guys does how many people is she asking
to sleep with her that's what I want I
mean does everyone give her a button
when they leave what's the
I mean I want to feel a little bit
special you know
question is for enormous what kind of
character development can we expect to
see in season six for Darrell first off
did you just call me enormous I did
maybe that was a Freudian you know the
minute you stood up I knew I liked you
no you better send that guy a balloon
emoji yes I once had a woman run of me
with her hand my crocks level but that
was a great party no and she and she I
worried I just wanted to check there was
something there she thought you were
really method I don't speak to my mother
anymore Oh somebody stepped on your foot
go ahead
I'm uncomfortable there's room can I sit
on James lab well I was hoping that was
mine
and we're done thank you very much you
know thinking days first question on a
day you're not my sister are you no okay
good exactly
I want a blood test no seriously because
that's I mean we all laugh about it but
can you when you follow it through that
must have been quite the traumatic
experience the Ferb for my character you
know what I'm saying because we were
both after in you know any times gonna
say I'm sorry I'm a huge fan of the show
I just wanted to start off by saying
oh hi question Oh
dear dad of your work hey how's your
pain tolerance
aren't you crawl and I'm going to take
you down
can we get those people
nobody's dressed up as my character for
some reason that's right exactly right I
don't know about that man lies I'm doing
my job well appreciate you thank you for
watching know if that's necessary ma'am
and fan children here Wow characters
it's dead
comic-con baby get into it
folio Aria has her list of people she
wants to kill but who do you have on
your list of people you want to kill no
I've actually pulled no sir I'm at
school I really enjoyed maths and it was
something that I enjoyed and in primary
school when I was like 12 was like my
leading subject and then when I went
into secondary school I just I started
to hate math because of my teachers and
I feel like that's what it is for a lot
of people it's like sometimes you don't
go on with your teachers and you start
to hate the subject I was just like
totally what happened with me so I
killed all three of my maths teachers
all three of them how hard is it to
maintain a relationship when you are a
companion to this man who snaps you up
at a moment's notice I'm gonna be honest
every time I try and do it it comes in
as like the Xbox
good I had this really weird experience
where before we started the movie I was
getting my kid a Halloween costume and
my son is really into Batman and why is
Lee and he he went to a store a costume
store in Los Angeles
it was pretty empty and I was in the
aisle and I heard this bully and I turn
around its Christian Bale it was the
sweetest guy and there he and I are
standing in the Batman comic and I said
look man you know you're the best like
what do you think you got any tips make
sure you drew Pierce in that suit
we're promoting an r-rated film the
first real r-rated superhero film on the
back of these it says please be aware
that many members of your audience may
be under 18 years of age yo and to those
of you I say you're gonna [ __ ] love
this movie yeah yeah all you hop with us
this far and I would ask you to come
just a little bit further with the green
arrow please no applause all right here
we go these are my people here we go
ah now that's the way to end a path
you got the Suicide Squad we've been in
Toronto this group right here we are
banging out something that is absolutely
fantastic and and stunning and this guy
right here David Ayer is the absolute
truth he's making something you ever
loved
did ya we'll see you all next year
Suicide Squad
you